bueno Generalmente un presidente que no
es popular puede generar un impacto en
las listas de senadores y obviamente en
los candidatos al congreso porque porque
obviamente no es popular porque las
políticas que estás llevando a cabo son
las que la electores Que obviamente no
están de acuerdo con él y que le dan un
rechazo a su gestión también quieren que
haya un cambio y este cambio se va
reflejado seguramente en que los
demócratas pierdan el control de la
cámara representantes y probablemente
también del senado ahora hemos visto a
alguien también haciendo distintos tipos
de actividades como parte de su campaña
por los demócratas hoy por ejemplo se
aplicó la última dosis de la vacuna
contra el covid 19 qué tanto pueden
funcionarle estas estrategias
el presidente está en una posición
difícil porque como muchos candidatos
saben que no es Popular en sus distritos
no lo quieren ahí pero a la vez es el
presidente y de una manera u otra es el
presidente del partido demócrata que es
el que está gobernando el presidente no
se va a quedar quieto ni se va a quedar
callado porque sería una admisión de que
su estrategia de gobierno ha fallado
Pero bueno obviamente va a ser todo lo
posible para que su partido no no pierda
y una de las cosas que puede llegar a
perder si los después llevas a pasar y
los demócratas pierden el control del
Congreso de ambas cámaras es que vayan
tenga que repensar tu estrategia de
reelección que él dice que quiere ser el
candidato del partido demócra pero por
ahí el partido demócrata no se lo
permite ahora tenemos también a los
republicanos que se han visto confiados
en que tendrán una victoria para ser
mayoría en las cámaras de legislativo
pero podríamos estar esperando sorpresas
mira hoy día en lo que se llama la
elección genérica que es una encuesta
que se hace en cada Distrito los
republicanos parecen tener una mayoría
no diría holgada necesito pero necesitan
solo cinco asientos cinco bancas para
alzarse con esas mayorías Por ende no es
una tarea tan difícil en un país que es
tan grande y donde los republicanos en
varios de esos distritos son bastante
más populares que hoy y en el partido
demócrata donde la inflación y el costo
de vida obviamente está haciendo media
para este partido que el gobierno No
ahora además de los escaños en el
congreso qué más está en juego en estas
elecciones del próximo 8 de noviembre y
hay gobernaciones obviamente pero lo más
importante en este momento es el
Congreso porque sin el control del
congresos o el con el control de es una
sola cámara se va a estar muy difícil
aún más difícil la vaiden gobernar
porque ya ves lo que ha pasado este año
el año pasado con tratar de aprobar
proyectos legislativos que
administración trató de empujar y que
quedaron varados entonces Imagínate que
hoy perdiendo una cámara se le va a
hacer aún más difícil que no es bueno
obviamente para un presidente que aspira
a la reelección como bailén ha dicho no